la pandémie de coronavirus frappe une
nouvelle fois la chine depuis ce mardi à
près de 5 millions de personnes sont
confinées
aujourd'hui les autorités sanitaires ont
fait état du premier décès lié au virus
depuis le mois de mai dernier
un décès qui s'est produit dans la
province de hebei est située dans le
nord-est du pays principal foyer de ce
regain épidémique 138 nouveaux cas
viennent d'être détectés en 24 heures
le bilan le plus élevé depuis le mois de
mars 2020 à des médecins expérimentés
ont d'ailleurs été envoyés dans la
région
beaucoup de membres de notre équipe ont
été à pékin kachkar et urumqi dans le
jing zhang pour aider à combattre le
virus dans ces endroits
donc on a tous assez d'expérience de
première ligne et c'est dans ce contexte
que des experts de louer mais ça arrive
aujourd'hui à guan berceau de la
pandémie
leur but enquêter sur les origines du
coronavirus les premiers cas détectés
intéresse particulièrement les
spécialistes ils tenteront également de
comprendre comment l'homme a pu
contracter la maladie
l'idée de faire avancer un certain
nombre d'études qui ont déjà été conçus
et décidé il ya quelques mois pour nous
permettre de mieux comprendre ce qui
s'est passé l'année dernière en décembre
et cela permettra d'examiner plus en
détail les cas initiaux les cas humains
qui ont été détectées en décembre 2019
en regardant les marchés le célèbre
marché de one et voir ce qui s'est passé
là-bas en essayant de découvrir tout ce
qui est entrée et sortie de ce marché
dans les semaines précédant les
événements afin d'aboutir et le market
d'après le bilan des autorités chinoises
avec près de 4700 décès enregistrés
depuis le début de la pandémie le pays
serait aujourd'hui
l'une des grandes puissances les moins
touchés au monde